welcome back to 8701 so in this lecture
we want to write down the 5-minute rules
for qcd
a lot of work happened to get to this
point if you
recall we derived feynman rules for toy
theory
then we extended this to qed quantum
electrodynamics introducing and keeping
track of the spin of particles
and now in qcd we have to do one step in
addition we
have to keep track of the color of
particles
so color the charge of qcd plays a
very important role here um if we just
investigate this fundamental process
here this fundamental vertex
which is very similar to a photon being
radiated from an electron here we have a
clue on
being radiated from quarks and when this
happens
the quark changes its color so here you
have a quark with color blue
and the cork with color red the clue on
adds a color it adds red but it also
takes
away the blue so the graph itself
basically carries two colors is
bi-colored um
one color and at the same time an
anti-color
a leading order process here i have two
vertices and this is a scattering for
example of two quarks which
other through a clue all right so we
have three kinds of charges
um meaning that the quarks come in
red green or blue so we have to keep
track of this when we write down
our amplitudes our matrix element so we
do this by just introducing a new vector
i call this c
here very simple a three element vector
for those three colors all right
but how about the gluon itself so qcd is
based on a symmetry group which is
called su3
so it's basically a rotation in a
three-dimensional space
there's eight independent such rotations
um and what you want to think about is
just moving
you know quarks from one color state
into the next
so you can write them down as i show
here and we do this in linear
combination of
color and andy color all right
if you want to keep track of this we do
this in this form we have a vector which
is a
element and you know the the um
gluon is one of those components this is
given here for this very first one
okay so let me introduce the notation
here
um literally we were introducing paulie
mattresses but not for su-2
as a symmetry group for with sco3
they're called the gel man mattresses
and they're just written here
again those are the rotations i was just
talking about so the rotation from one
color state into the next
there's commutator relations for this um
so if you have two of those
matrices and you try to write down the
common commutator
you find this two times i
times this structure functions or
structure constants
times one
the next well the next gelman matrix
so if you're just thinking about how
many combinations are there there's
eight matrices
we have eight times eight times eight
combinations
of those constants here and so which
means that there's about
there is 512 of those constant most of
them are zero
and the ones which are not zero they're
listed here or combinations of those
all right so now we have we are ready to
just write down the qcd um feynman rules
again we start from the external lines
so for the incoming quark
or outgoing quark we write our spinor
and then we keep track of color okay
we do this for quarks and we do this for
antiquarks in the very same way
for the glue on now we have to keep our
polarization
um keep track of the polarization of the
plume
and also of the color and those are the
vectors i was just
i just introduced on the previous slide
okay for the propagators we have quarks
and antiquarks in gluons
gluons are masses so the propagator here
looks very much like the one for the
for the um uh for
for the photon and the propagator for
the quarks looks very much like the one
we had for the electron and qed
the fundamental vertices i introduced
one already
but there is two more um
that's because gluon carries charge and
can couple to itself
we already discussed it in a recitation
so we have those
self couplings of the gluon here and
those vertices
are you know as relevant or more
relevant even
than than the one here all right
so the vertices come with a vertex
factor in our use
in our firemen rules again for this very
first one we find a very similar one
as we had before you see here this this
scaleman matrix and that just
causes the rotation and color um but we
have this three gluon vertex in the
foreglow and vertex as well
and those come with structure functions
here
um to keep track of the permutation
communications between being color
involved
and it becomes more complicated for this
four vertex
for gluon vertex which has pairs of
those structure constants
each all right so that that's
all we need in order to calculate matrix
elements or amplitudes
for qcd the rest is just executing the
fireman rules
as we did before for our toy theory and
also for qed